hey everyone Alessandro here and we got
some early game play from moons of
madness essentially a cross between the
Martian and the deep psychological
horrors of HP Lovecraft the main
character must confront the elements of
Mars while coming into conflict with the
dark supernatural force that pushes his
mental state to its limits how does this
game look to you be sure to comment
below and subscribe to our channel for
more videos on moons of madness and
other titles that blend John Rose
together in surprising ways thanks for
watching
oh come on you can honestly sit there
and tell me you believe the stones were
superior and their music to Bowie his
musical genius my friend was legend our
mothers and their mothers listen to
bands our grandparents group do way back
when oh listen I just just passed point
Griffin I still don't think it looks
like a Griffin you should look at the
shadow play and take into account a
distinct coloration and morphological
idiosyncrasy of the formation it comes
across as more like a great person
I seem to have a situation here okay
okay
scan the old meerkat with the bio Gage
and it should zero in on the problem
textbook stuff hell you wrote half the
textbook so you know this better than me
[Music]
so what's the status on that meerkat
give me a sitrep just for the lock power
is intermittent from what I can make out
life support online comms online she
just won't move power distribution may
be compromised luckily my readings put
you just about less than half a klick
away from the solar array there's a
large power conduit atop the ridge near
the rover's right-hand side I see where
you're going with this
yeah you're thinking I need to science
my way out using the conduits stored
energy that's right all you need to do
is connect the power cable from the
stern of the America to the arrays
energy output cord fair enough kind of
lucky that this happened here I guess
glad to see you're treading the bright
side chain
I take it you're outside counts for the
radio silence beautiful place this red
rock doesn't matter how many times you
see here I can stare at her for a
millennia and hunger for more
hey I'm burning oxygen here dead in the
water remember right back to the
business at hand
you don't better force but if I remember
correctly on the stern of the meerkat
there you should see a casing that would
be your power cable
all right family cable you know the rest
cable the conduit toughly to housing and
the juice is loose hey Orson I've got
some fairly hefty power fluctuations
down here I'm gonna need you to run a
diet on the power conduit flush out any
faults along the system we'll look into
it
check that out
[Music]
[Music]
Orson it's nothing never mind
must must have just been a trick of the
light
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know there's a lot about this place
that reminds me of my mother not your
standard type of Association no I
suppose not
it's Wow it's the vast emptiness I
suppose the silence and solitude of it
all in some ways I mean she had us her
family we were always there but even
then you got a sense that she could
stand in a room with a hundred people it
wasn't easy for
whoa a whole section of the rigging here
is collapsed some sort of structural
damage maybe
[Music]
forcing forcing are you there come in
Orson
hold a moment
well when it rains it pours I guess I'm
reading the current output of current to
be well below what you need to charge
the meerkats main battery of course it
is any ideas juice out of old Saul
[Music]
there's no wait what
if you can hear me it it wasn't here
before I'm seeing a cave that shouldn't
be here
okay okay I'm going into the cave or
city I don't know if you can hear me I'm
uh I'm going to investigate I I don't
see what else I can do at this point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Jane are you here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
someone's here sweet
I can hear them
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this I I remember this as I write this
your father tells me you should just be
coming into orbit so high above us I
cannot imagine how exhilarating your
stay on the training station must be but
I know what pride fills your father's
voice when he speaks of it a pride only
mirrored in my own eyes and to think you
are somewhere up there looking down on
me like a guardian angel
you always were even when my troubles
would take me making sure I didn't hurt
myself making sure your sister who
didn't see but don't think on this my
lovely boy I could not be happier with
your decision to pursue your dreams
among the stars I will be well enough
the troubles don't come to me so often
these days
and your father always helps me albeit
in his own gruff way ever the military
man he thinks I can will the darkness
away through mental discipline and a
healthy regimen who knows
maybe I can everything will be fine here
I promise look to yourself Shane look to
the stars I will write again soon your
loving mother
[Applause]
don't come take your sister in right now
go play hide-and-seek but don't go into
the dark they like
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
are you good your comms are unresponsive
and I'm getting some fairly odd readings
here please respond
are you good